Drake reunites his Degrassi cast but who
got left out meanwhile ariana grande is
pulling double-duty
her new tracks with Nicki Minaj and
choice of on Plus Christina Aguilera is
back and better than ever
happy Friday my people it's the end of
the week and you know what that means
it's new music Friday here on the daily
Deni where do I even begin okay it's the
music video everybody is talking about
Drake pulled off the most epic and
probably expensive Degrassi next
generation reunion in the video for his
latest single I'm upset Drake who played
student Jimmy Brooks brought together
some of his old co-stars for the
nostalgia field video half a million oh
my head I can't accept this it made me
feel like someone tried a best you want
to waste half a million be my guests
make me wanna 5s and a tech but I'm best
I just checked Jamie never met me and a
fascist as you can tell tensions rise in
typical Degrassi fashion but that goes
for the storyline in the video as well
as behind the scenes the big reunion
included a slew of former cast members
like Nina Dobrev Jake Epstein even Jason
Mewes and Kevin Smith as Jay and Silent
Bob notably missing though was Daniel
Clark who played Shawn
Cameron apparently he was left out and
only learned about the reunion when he
saw the video like the rest of us idea
that this happened like I woke up just
as surprised as everyone else all the
I also had just heard about it for the
first time and was watching it for the
first time so I know there's been a lot
of buzz about what happened or why I
wasn't a part of the video I honestly I
wish I had an answer for you guys I
don't know
as far as I can tell like I've never
really never really had any problem
today
oh no he's upset pun totally intended
all right no word from Drake yet why the
snub but meanwhile he also revealed the
cover art to his next album scorpion
that jobs on June 29th well from one
member of The Young Money family to
another Nicki Minaj is serving us her
latest sexy Bop
vet which reunites her with Ariana
Grande
[Music]
get a city laughs is it just me or do we
need a full collab album from these two
Nicki and re together is always fire but
each do have their own big solo things
coming up
Nicki's highly anticipated fourth album
Queen drops August 10th and she also
shared in unretouched snippet of the
video for bed with our ease okay of
course thousand dollar sheets where is
but you want some thousand other sheets
I've got caught at three younger people
back shuts to the beat up no I mean I
can let you get the Milly on you know
yes yes yes I need more of that
meanwhile Ari is a busy girl pulling
double even triple duty her new song the
light is coming will be released next
week but in the meantime she is featured
on choice of Vaughn's new single dance
to this
[Music]
we can just
I love that Arianna has been recruited
for two sultry songs and this one came
as a surprise to Troy who told fans on
Instagram live he loved the song but
felt like it needed a female voice
without getting too excited Troy reached
out to Arianna directly who said yes
very quick Ari is like literally one of
the coolest people I've ever met she's
so chill and cool and like real and like
actually nice and funny and like not in
a oh my god we have to get coffee way
like check in with you on a random day
like how are you doing kind of thing
what's up I want to see you like real
person not caught up in any of the book
and I know I said it a million times but
so and funny like so funny and this goes
without saying but her voice is like the
I think like the best out of everybody
she's just like she's just the best and
so I've told her this but like I'm so
thankful that she's on this song it's
like such a gift to me
speaking of gift after teasing fans for
what felt like a decade Christina
Aguilera is finally back with a brand
new album liberation but is way worth
the wait guys Xtina
gave fans in New York also an even
bigger surprise performing in the subway
in disguise with Jimmy Fallon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very much we like to do one more someone
free if you don't mind right here first
I'd like to introduce ourselves my name
is uh my name is Jimmy Fallon
[Applause]
I love that so much all right liberation
is out now have you guys given to listen
to it yet let me know what tracks are
listening to our repeat this weekend and
I'll see you back here on Monday with
another dose of daily Deni until then
cheers my friend
[Music]